time for who need to adjust the SKT
system but clearly they feel a lot of
confidence in him nicely done Unni
coming down and man this guy is on fire
so far for SDP duty man he's looking
good on tanks amps I have to say if
anybody who's good at legal legends it
doesn't matter if your tanker dealer we
can play any champion first game here Oh
gianna where the lck and we are just
chock-full of surprises I like it we
could be seen the debut of the 2017 well
chat know do you say maokai which i
guess we should have talked about a bit
more on champion select has played these
tanks from time to time and predictably
you can play ribbon if you can play the
difficult champion not life's pretty
straight across interrupts the charge
here comes peanut scar looks like
they're going to end the game right here
45 minutes teleporting in onto the super
minion it's going to be multiple minion
waves and a foodie who is unkillable in
the front line and can I put up a good
defense but SKT predictably get it done
in the lock they get the ball rolling
and it just doesn't stop
SK Telecom 17 to 10 in the end with a 14
bowels of gold we take down Jin air
first question answered Ken who knee
played tanks well he's played maokai
before seemed pretty good on it here he
went the most supportive build you could
ever uh who got the locket who got the
Knights valve both of them from hooning
and your MVP on debuts on debut is
tuning on Mount Baker in one of the
interview session you know I wasn't sure
if he was going to play furiously but
he's been practicing extremely hard and
seems like he has earned that starting
spot on this roster
healthy open watches go decided here
comes unni knock two up with the keepers
verdict devour coming through from still
flower on to exude would whooping on the
road down gonna try to lock them up with
her splashes bored find zigzoo the Excel
comes out throws of the hangers will
cause i'm up son into the wall on Teddy
by who any figure coming around the
backside I mean fantastic response by
honey as well immediately channeling its
heliport when they saw that abyssal
voyage it's not just credit show up
dentist me you'll be alright however
well head coming over the wall jump in
onto the stage and they take them out
tries to get through the space case but
it can't do it who D finishing them off
the Nexus exposed they will work their
way through them and there we have it a
swift to zero coming through for SKT
rather forty minutes and forty five for
both games insanity what these guys can
do I just know what I was doing I think
that's why we came up with a win
Guney is showing that he can really open
up his champion lineup is champion pool
as well so another ping comes down oh
look at this row he's gonna get one be
one of the top lane Hootie man he's
looking good on one tank camps I have to
say I'm gonna take a quick replay of
that you can see that Unni has a freeze
on actually meanwhile he goes for the
kill on to Roach who flashed early but
it wasn't going to matter anyway oh here
comes Unni on bed can heal and the pin
nope but he is going to old in and here
comes the exhaust bakery once I kill the
last car and he does get the kills
nicely done Mooney coming down and man
this guy is on fire so far for STP when
he really needs to defend this turret
does have that spirit visage you can
examine any damage yes sitting there
throwing everything out of curtain call
coming down on some souls on to damage
but no man on peanut here suni though
you put floods gotta do it all himself
just gathers Baker on the left side dude
Junie just does not die SJP with the
dominating first game sorry
jumping at the game number two of SKT vs
Kong you monster I feel like Camille is
a champion you don't want to get some
uni and then a rengar you definitely
don't want to give the people I think
cooties just kind of reads out of that
oh it's going to be flashed on column
and here comes punch the ultimate coming
in Judi is trying to turn on here he's
going to be kicked away and it's almost
going down to that and hoody it looks
like he's going to get away in a very
weird turn of events SK Telecom actually
gets really far ahead off that attempt
this game can combo and sk d continue
winning their games by landslides it's
now four and a half thousand gold going
over to sk p booty is unbelievably
farmed right now this does the slaughter
man for 18 minutes to the game they're
nine thousand gold ahead hold that
damage from swinging hold on it looks
like roach and punch might want to go in
on this both getting really low and try
to jump on it there they do get wolf but
look at bang in the bag really pushing
out the total damage but they all coming
out of Cassiopeia and detectives going
to take out bang Tony's still alive
somehow someway this is the last stand
for Kobe monster if they do even because
I won some pretty go I didn't see him
punch she's going to make another
greatest and the sounds of the Nexus and
SPC takes another 200 vigorous yeah and
the way that they cook this game would
play better than name number one this
was from start to finish
absolute knowledge universe abolishing
Roach up in top SKP looking to be one of
the stronger teams here can't wait until
they be top again
you know whenever my teammates are doing
well it really helps me it really frees
me up gives me a lot of freedom to make
the place that I want to make you know I
thought it was about time I bring out a
damage dealer like gangplank because I
was I wanted to send the other teams a
message I could still play these
champions guys don't forget about him
[Music]